investigators in North Carolina believed
that they found the body of a missing
six-year-old boy
Maddox rich who has autism was reported
missing last Saturday his father says
that his son ran away from him in a park
but he couldn't catch him because he has
medical issues with his legs a body was
discovered yesterday in a shallow creek
nearby Manuel Bojorquez is in Gastonia
near the park
where the child reportedly disappeared
and well good morning good morning more
than 300 investigators and searchers
spent nearly a week poring over hundreds
of leads and looking through thousands
of acres out here for any sign of Maddox
rich in the end even though they believe
they have found his body there are still
many unanswered questions I'm
heartbroken Gastonia Police Chief Robert
Helton struggled to speak Thursday while
announcing investigators believe they
found the body of missing six year old
Maddox rich our communities are broken
our searchers our investigators this is
not the end that we'd hoped for Maddox
who had autism and was nonverbal was
last seen Saturday at Rankin Lake Park
in Gastonia his father told police he
couldn't catch up when the boy ran after
a jogger there's a lot of information
indicating the Maddox was where the
family indicated he was and that his
movements were what they indicated
hundreds of investigators spent nearly a
week by ere foot and boat looking for
Maddox Thursday afternoon authorities
said 15 searchers found a body
camouflaged in a shallow creek roughly a
mile from the park in an area that had
been searched before at this point what
is your investigation looking to answer
right now how did he get there what was
the manner of death what was the cause
of death was there any crime that was
committed or are we simply looking at an
accident my baby back in my arms
earlier this week Maddox his parents
both made emotional public pleas for
information leading to his safe return
mr. Trapp I just want my little boy back
home in a lengthy Facebook post Thursday
night Maddox his father
Ian rich thanked investigators and said
he is distraught today I found out I'm
not a dad anymore he wrote I would give
anything to go
back and save him that's a nice picture
and it's really heartbreaking the body
was found near Steven Early's house he
and other community members say they are
devastated formal identification of the
body could take days in the meantime
police say they would still like to
speak with anyone else who is at this
park at the time of the disappearance
they say there is a man described to be
in a white truck that they would still
like to locate they believe he may have
been the last person to see Maddox John
Manuel thanks Mannix's sweet face and
very very tough story